unplug your toaster and put earmuffs on
your webcam because we are at war with
machines personally I've been terrified
of them ever since I saw that
documentary wall-e
damn those robots for making me cry
these tin cans are coming for our cars
they're coming for our sex lives and
they've been coming for our jobs for
years ever since the first water wheel
replaced Jeremiah the mill boy I tell
you no one liked to crank it more than
that guy but thankfully one small
business owner is raging Against the
Machine trademark look this is Fabio he
was given a trial run with hopes he
would assist customers with their
shopping needs but after just a wee
Fabio was fired you would ask where the
cheese is and he would say in the fridge
or where's the beer well it's in the
alcohol house so he really wasn't
helping customers
a supermarket greeter who really wasn't
helping customers damnit they perfectly
replicated human behavior that robot is
exactly like the 17 year old stoner who
doesn't want to work there look at it
it's already at a hoverboard and it's
programmed with attitude can you tell me
where the milk is I don't know can I
pitch perfect and I'm claiming a victory
because this bot lost its job but they
fired it in a completely wrong manner
the mirror says when Fabio was told it
was being let go and asked are you angry
come on it's tricked you into firing it
like a human you could just unplug it
and put it back in the box take it
outside
don't let to look at the river and talk
about the rabbits then power off just
don't tell the thing it's fired because
this firing might be what finally turns
these gear heads from rumbas to doom bus